due to a marine heatwave several warm
water sea creatures have been appearing
on the beaches of Northern California
that's right big article on this it
includes sea cucumbers jellyfish even
sea eels
well did you just say sea eels yeah
I said sea eels yeah then nobody's safe
oh man I knew this day would come
Annie relax it's a temporary just
weather thing and besides it's just some
CEOs what's the big deal
gosh you're so naive sure it's just some
CEOs today but these guys are smart
they're basically snakes that can hold
their breath underwater pretty soon
you're gonna start coordinating with the
river eels the lake hills and the Landy
wait a minute Andy land eels and faster
than you can say pelvic fins the weaker
humans are naturally going to start
worshipping eels and we're looking at a
full-scale eel eel pocalypse
Wow if you want to see yourself and your
family and slave buy eels be my guest
but I say no thank you
I am out of here Andy you are completely
overreacting there is no such thing as
an eel pocalypse oh yeah tell it to
those guys
our hour has arrived to the rocky shores
of Santa Barbara to greet our new eel
masters save yourself Conan I'm going
underground Annie
handy handy where are you going all
right yeah okay boys I am ready to make
some money and that's how you give a
conan taping
you